- On this episode, I talk
about selling merchandise,
how to price sponsorship of your show
and Tim Ferriss stops by.
(hip hop music)
You ask questions and I answer them.
This is The #AskGaryVee Show.
(hip hop music)
- [Voiceover] People are
mourning for the beard.
- Uh, sure, sorry guys.
(laughs)
You know what, I like it.
I think I look very fresh.
(laughs)
The other thing that I like is
through that whole beard experiment
I realized that you can
keep your facial hair
the same exact size all
the time if you want to
so I think I'm gonna by a trimmer
and this is two days.
I think it's like five or six
days that I like the length
and I may have a permanent
5 o'clock shadow.
- [Voiceover] Like Rhode's scruff.
- Yeah, exactly.
- [Voiceover] He rocks it, yeah.
- It's so funny, I don't
know why I didn't recognize
that you're able to do that.
(laughs)
I literally just thought
people's facial hair just stopped
and mine just kept going.
(laughs)
And other's just kept going
but like, it's really a very basic thing
that I just didn't understand
happened in the world.
Yep, anyway that's quite sad.
91?
- [India] 91.
- Hey, everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and you're watching episode 91
of The #AskGaryVee Show.
You may also be listening to it.
Little rusty from not doing
a show for six or seven days
so I said watched instead of this is.
91, a tremendous number.
Number of my favorite New
York Jet, Sheldon Richardson.
The NFL draft is on Thursday.
I'm filming, recording this on a Tuesday.
So, if you're watching it right
now or tonight or tomorrow
I want you to know that
I am going to Chicago
for the NFL draft and I
fully intend to be the face
of the New York Jets pick
because I don't expect as
many Jet fans in Chicago
as normally in New York.
I will be cozying up to the cameraman
both on the NFL network and ESPN.com
and I'm very confident that the Jets
will select x, y, z, player.
They will pan to fans
and it will be me and A.J.
saying yay or boo.
So I'm excited for that, look for that.
Let's get in to the show, India.
- [Voiceover] Aaron asks--
- Actually, before we get into the show...
I missed not doing the
show for six or seven days.
Miss everybody.
Big ups to everyone on Meerkat
and now, India, let's get into the show.
- [Voiceover] Aaron asks--
- Oh, wait, I'm just kidding. (laughs)
Go ahead, go ahead.
- [Voiceover] "Everyone
visiting my site will be there
"for custom music, should
I delay them with content?"
- Aaron this is a very
interesting question
for a very specific reason.
If you watching the Meerkat, I kind of
had to talk to India four or
five times on this question
and I didn't really, fully get it
and then I realized, aha
that's why I don't get it.
Because of the way you position
the question, my friend.
If you notice the sentence structure,
something I never understood
'cause I have no grammar skills.
You say delay them with content.
That, in itself, is the problem.
It's the energy that you
approach this question with.
Which is that, you're
saying to yourself
do I put out content that
is in my best interest
instead of theirs,
hence the word delay.
And the way I
always talk about it,
is putting out content that
actually brings value to people.
And so, when I say a pop-up.
You know, when I say,
don't stop them from going
to what they want to, that's a pop-up ad
that's not bringing them any value.
If you put out content
that isn't the music
but maybe it's
the behind the scenes
of you remixing the music,
getting the music,
your thoughts on the music.
If you bring them other value
well then you're bringing value.
I mean, people watch this
show to get to the answers.
Do they enjoy the
banter that I had before
when me and India make
before we get into the show?
Or my Jets thing or whatever?
You know, I think
there's a certain subset
that does enjoy that.
And that's why I've
been able to pull off
video show after video show
'cause I'm trying
to make it interesting
with other things besides
the hardcore content.
Some people think
that's too much,
they don't like it and
they won't be there.
But at the end of the day, the
fact that you say delay them
with content means that
the energy in the seed
of how you're
approaching it is wrong.
What you need to do is make
that value added content.
Make that part of
the overall experience.
Make that the
reason they come.
And I think that
that is something that
people really misunderstand.
I think the Mets have a much
better stadium than the Yankees
because of all the added venues
and the nuances and the
ambiance of their stadium.
I'm there for the ball game.
People are there
for the ball game
but there's always a added
value of why you're there.
It might be a
dart board in a bar.
Is the dart board
there to stop them
from drinking another beer?
No, it adds, so
let's add VaynerNation.
Let's not subtract.
It's interesting the
way he asked that.
- [India] Yeah, it is.
It's like he's
already against it.
- He's already against it.
It's already not for them.
It needs to be for them.
Zak.
(laughs)
- Hey Gary, Chirstophe here
with scaleyourcode.com.
How would you price
sponsorships for an episode
of a show like #AskGaryVee?
Would you go by
the number of views?
By the number of sales they get?
What do you think?
Thanks Gary.
- Yes.
I think that there's a
very simple answer to this.
My big belief, when
you're selling sponsorship
to something new is you ask
for as much as possible.
And I'm not kidding.
You don't know where your ceiling is.
If you go by cpm's and views
you're really in a tough spot because
views and impressions
have been commoditized
to such a level that you'll
never hit enough scale.
Most people are
gonna make four dollars
on their show sponsorship
if they go that route.
It's the association,
notice I don't run ads
or sell sponsorship on this show
and if I did, I would
expect substantial bank.
Because not only,
it's not about the
20, 30, 40, 50 thousand YouTube
and 50, 60, 70, 80 thousand
Facebook imperssions
and awareness and
all that nature.
It's about the brand association.
I'm endorsing it by accepting it
'cause I've never
done it before.
And so there's an
extra value on that.
So I think, the thing that
you really need to think about
is if it's a small
business, start up,
you need to negotiate.
There needs to be just a
price and you start high.
If it's a media buying agency,
you're already in trouble
because they're looking to buy
scale and they're really looking
to commoditize your traffic
and that is not gonna make
sense for 99.9% of the people
listening and watching
this show and so
my advice is to price it--
and then the second
part of your question
about the conversion of sales.
You don't wanna
be in direct response,
conversion based
business either.
What you wanna be is in the
brand association pricing, right.
You can't put a price on a
small business-oriented solution
being a sponsor of this
show because they're getting
to entrepreneurs and
executives through this channel
and there's more depth than width.
So I would price it as
high as humanly possible
and let it land to where
the market actually says.
I think one of the big mistakes
that a lot of my friends
who watch this show and lot
of people that negotiate
in general, they don't
price accordingly
because they ask
for what they want.
And usually, you should
at least double or triple
what you want to leave
room for the negotiation.
Or, you know, a lot of times
you're limiting your upside
by not recognizing
that you missed
or underpriced your value prop.
- [Voiceover] Bunch of
Deckheads wants to know,
"If you're selling merch,
like t-shirts,
"how would you go about doing it?"
- Well, Deckheads, I mean--
This is a very good question.
I like this question.
I don't wanna beat dead horse
but I would say
Facebook dark post
is incredibly interesting.
The targeting capabilities
of what's going on
in that platform are incredible.
I think Pinterest
and promoted pins
is another place
that I would spend
a ton of time and energy.
And I would say
traditional digital
even though it's something
I like to pick on.
I think SEM, Google AdWords
and I think banner retargeting,
you know, people
landing on your site,
you pixeling them
and cookieing them
from the traffic that you
got from the other places
and then retargeting
them on banner
and things of that nature
have all been proven
t-shirt, hoodie, hat selling.
I think Facebook dark posts,
though are incredible.
The fact that you can
target people that are fans
of Teespring or BustedTees
or all these kind of
Threadless, JackThreads,
all these places
where those kind of things
are sold, Johnny Cupcakes.
The fact that you can target
to that level, just incredible.
I mean like, you know (scoffs)
It's really a funny
thing to do this show
because I keep
pounding this narrative
and so many of you
continue not to do it.
But a couple of you are
starting to email me saying,
hey, thank you for this because
this is what's happened.
So that makes me happy,
makes me continue to wanna
spew the best advice
possible, and to me
50% of my money
would be allocated
to Facebook dark posts but
the other 50% allocated
to things I just told you about.
By the way, Staphon,
this whole episode
I don't watch my stuff, I
don't know what you guys
have been doing from
an editing standpoint.
But even this part, right now,
in color when it's the show.
In black and white
when it's not.
The part where I yelled
Zak, I like that part.
This right now, got it?
Our talking, got it?
We've been doing it?
People like it, right?
- [Staphon] Um-hm.
- I like it.
On that note.
- [Voiceover] Yes.
- On that note,
let's go right into it.
Guys, India and I continue
to wanna bang out articles.
If you have had success
with any of the tactics
from the #AskGaryVee Show,
here's your chance to get
totally humongous exposure
because we'll write an article of like,
four business that
have benefitted from
The #AskGaryVee Show.
And India will interview you.
She'll call you,
she's very sweet.
You'll give her advice--
You'll give her advice,
excuse me,
you'll give her
the details and bam.
We'll blast it out
there and more people,
more customers, more
good stuff, don't lie.
Just to hack, to get in there.
Truth, I want proof, India
'cause VaynerNation
can get a little shady.
(laughs)
- [Voiceover] Edward
wants to know,
"What's the biggest way, right now,
"you are hypocritical of
your won advice?"
- (sighs) Edward, this
is a really, really,
really, good question.
Edward, this may be my favorite question.
You know what, Edward, you've also solved
something else for me, that is tremendous.
Which is people always ask
me, you know this Steve.
"What's the one question
nobody ever asks you,
that should ask you?"
(laughs)
I think this is really it.
Edward, it's a moving target.
Right now, luckily, 'cause
I've built out infrastructure
a lot less, right, I'm
putting out content.
I'm doing a consistent show.
Andy K. doing a ton of
Facebook dark posts.
We're doing a ton of
influencer stuff on Instagram.
I would say maybe a little bit,
we need a little bit
more umph on Pinterest
but even that we're doing, huh.
I would say this,
in the historical track
of me giving advice
since 2009 in business,
this is easily the least hypocritical,
least not following my advice
that I've ever been in
because I finally hit
scale where I can afford
this incredibly good-looking team.
Show Steve for the good-looking stuff.
- Hello there.
- And so (laughs).
And so...
What do you guys think, actually?
This could be a lot of fun.
I'm trying to think of like
what we're not crushing on
that we believe in so much.
We're really doing well right now.
- I think, I don't know.
- [Gary] Go ahead, it's okay
you won't hurt my feelings.
- Okay, I think that we could probably be
jabbing on Wine Library better.
I think that a lot of--
- No, I don't well,
by the way, come back to me.
Wine Library is like out of the,
I think for sure.
Wine Library's got Instagram
that it could be doing better.
Pinterest.
Wine Library's got its
own spiel of re-orging
in a way that I think can do better work.
Wine Library for sure.
I'm talking about our world
where I have a little bit more control
because I'm day-to-day Wine Library.
What do you think is the, India?
Anything?
- [Voiceover] Hmm.
- I think SlideShare.
- [Voiceover] Yeah.
- I'm a big, right, SlideShare.
I think we've really, that's me and you.
- [India] Yeah.
- And maybe I could be
giving a little bit more time
and access to India and Steve
for the follow up content.
I'm just like grinding so hard.
I mean like...
There's just like not a minute in the day.
I'm mean like, we're literally
like talking on Sunday nights
- [India] Yeah.
- It's pretty intense.
6pm this last Sunday.
So, I don't know.
I don't know, I'm feeling
really great right now about it.
As good as I've ever felt.
Wine Library as a whole
could be doing better.
Definitely on Instagram.
There's so much upside
for wine businesses there.
I could be giving a little bit more access
to following up on content.
I don't know.
- [Steve] Could be making
more episodes of
The #AskGaryVee Show.
- More episodes.
We're grinding pretty good right now.
But I want that question
asked once a quarter
'cause I think it will matter.
- Hey Gary, Tim Ferriss here.
Cheers, top of the morning to ya.
And I have a question because I look like
Al Pacino after a bender.
I am launching the Tim Ferriss Experiment
and it is a hell of a thing. (laughs)
How do you think television
shows will be launched
two years from now?
Both in terms of distribution
and in terms of commercial?
That is my question
because there's gotta be
many better ways (laughs).
Thank you.
- Tim, great to have you on the show.
I know so many of the
people in the VaynerNation
are huge fans so that's a lot of fun.
I'm sure a lot of you enjoyed that.
And everybody in the VaynerNation
should actually check out Tim's
Tim Ferriss Experiment on iTunes.
Staphon let's link that up and YouTube.
And I'm sure it's easy
to find for all of you
that are listening on the podcast
and on Facebook, if you're watching.
Can one of you maybe jump in
with a quick comment up when this episode
pops up on Facebook and link to iTunes?
Tim Ferriss Experiment.
Timmy, I think that a
couple things will happen.
One, I think there's gonna be
a crap load more over
the top services, right.
So, you've got Netflix but
I think you've got Vimeo
starting to make some noise.
I expect a lot of traditional,
old-school digital leaders
to get in this game.
Microsoft's gonna have to be in this game.
Yahoo!'s gonna have to be in this game.
I think, Snapchat is clearly
a television network.
I think Facebook in a lot
of ways goes that route.
I think everybody that
can own video is gonna try
'cause all the money's there.
I think launching it will happen
in the way that you're
doing it now, right?
You're asking this question
in a micro community,
where I'm now giving exposure to it.
And so the days of going to the Today Show
or running commercials on a big show.
Or trying to get print or
radio like campaigns going,
there's now all these fragmented societies
and niches, Facebook dark posts.
Making infographics for Pinterest.
Getting a ton of Instagram's influencers,
having me on Mike's show.
I'm sure you're probably
hitting the podcast circuit
tremendously hard.
You're probably gonna
show up on 15 podcasts
over the next week or two.
Which is something you wouldn't
have done 24 months ago.
And there will be five
to seven other things
that none of know has the
attention of the consumer.
Maybe an app that comes
out on the watch, right?
There's so much coming.
And so, here's what I can tell you.
I don't predict, I react.
But I do know this,
in 24 months, there
will be some new shtuff.
Shtuff.
I almost said shit and then stuff.
Shit and stuff means shtuff.
That's how it comes out of my mouth.
Question of the day.
What is good question of the day?
Ah, I'm gonna go very football on you.
What is your favorite football team?
Who do you want your team to take?
One of you lucky Vayniacs
will get an opportunity of me buying
a jersey of your favorite
team's actual pick
if you predict it properly
in the comments section.
Of YouTube.
That's right, and you know what,
and Facebook.
So, what's your favorite football team?
And who do you want them to select?
If you're right, you may
get that person's jersey
as a surprise by me.
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
- [Gary] Hey, Chris Rock.
(laughs)
- Serious?
- [Gary] Yeah, there is, there's a chat.
- [Gary] Hey Chris.
- So cool.
- [Gary] Carey B's the
man, Chris Rock, Meerkat.
You missed the holy
shit Chris (beep) Rock.
Gary, Chris, are well.
- Yeah, it's Chris (beep) Rock.
(laughs)
(hip hop music)